aujourd'hui les applications ds que tu
as essayé des choses un peu nouvelle
pourrait séduire l'amour aussi mauléon
boîte de nuit au restaurant dans un oued
en trombe
voilà la tse marié voyage là ça s'est
passé le 9 juin dernier à los angeles à
l'épousé qui s'amassent algues avec les
marines garric et son prof de tennis
neo
[Musique]
m
une faux rythme et malheureusement n'a
plus autant d'argent qu'avant lui
resterait que 60 millions de dollars et
la maison
du coup comme elle n'a plus beaucoup de
trésorerie elle a fait énormément de
partenariat pour ce mariage d'ailleurs
c'est pour ça qu'on la voit aujourd'hui
sur les réseaux après le mariage a
remercié les prestataires à faire
beaucoup de story pour sa robe pour les
décorateurs etc etc on appelle ça des
partenariats il faut quand même relevé
le mauvais goût de ce mariage entre le
bisou pour tourner là la calèche de
disneyland ya une mini jupe rouge
cemagref de prince héritier
icône donatella versace alors vous
barrymore à droite
selena gomez ne dit pas oui madonna
jours amende à
harris et donatella alors oui paris s'il
tonne et
une des plus grosses pas une réputation
mais en tout cas un mystère autour de
michael jackson c'est le rapport qu'il
avait avec les enfants il a souvent été
victime d'accusations de pédophilie je
voulais savoir quel était ton point de
vue il ya beaucoup de d'enfants en fait
c'est des menteurs y en a beaucoup qui
ont menti de ce qu'on avait de reportage
sur m6 si on parle de ce reportage il a
dit qu'il a eu des attouchements dans un
petit train alors vérifiant le petit
train n'a jamais existe pourquoi ces
deux gamins ont menti déjà tous les deux
étaient très amoureux de lui ah oui
pense est très jaloux l'un de l'autre
parce que bon maintenant des deux en
effet je l'avais sur une tournée mais il
était avec ses parents atari vous et
vient des deux gamins sur la tournée
avec les parents jackie
14 14 ans 13 me suis pas sûr que le mot
soldes c'est plus tard plus tard
d'accord qu'on dise on était plus âgé en
effet ils ont ils avaient une adoration
pour michael donc il y avait une espèce
de jalousie il vous a parlé vous dit
qu'il voulait se convertir à l'époque à
l'islam c'est vrai ça avant de mourir
son frère germain le pousser ouais à se
convertir à l'islam ouais mais il ne l'a
pas fait finalement fait lui s'intéresse
à toutes les religions pour s'instruire
d'accord et dont l'islam il a lu le
coran en entier ah oui pour s'instruire
oui donc il l'a pas fait il là m'avait
dit d'accord non c'est véridique il ne
l'a pas fait et d'ailleurs y porter main
le petit ruban rouge qu'un rabbin un
grand rabbin lui a offert hier il a mis
là jamais quitté puisqu'il fallait
attendre que sa tombe mais de toutes les
façons lui il avait une soif vraiment de
s'instruire sur les religions dernière
question sur madonna guillemets de na
waie toi ou moi j'adore malo là mais je
mets falloir aussi parce que tous ses
fans femme vous avez vous été choqué de
sa nouvelle de sa nouvelle aile et
beaucoup d'enfants mais et je voulais
savoir si ça l'avait un peu des
comportements de divas son physique son
d'ensilage madonna que vous êtes bien
connu
c'est une diva je dirais même moi
c'était une divin mais tout ce que je
vois là dernièrement aussi bien danser
installera mois sur les réseaux ça ne
l'est plus pour moi c'est plus du tout
ça vous touche plus non alors que sam
touché avant bien sûr j'adorerais adoré
c'est pour ça quand je produisais ce
concert c'était bon c'était la plus
grande quand même très 10 mai recul et
je sais que vous vous êtes fan de
freddie mercury et laurent gapenne comme
tout le monde je pense que non mais on a
beaucoup parlé de ses rapports à la
drogue quand on les producteurs très
divers accueillait ce que on est je
posais la question d'ailleurs cash
fournisseurs de substances de temps en
temps moi je suis mobutu des rares très
bien mais frédéric traini ouais donc
après le concert qui était à
l'hippodrome de vincennes on est allés
chez castel et c'est là qu'il est
ce que tu peux me trouver faute de
l'herbe ouais et mongi ben annoncé que
moi j'en fume pas ni rien et je ne sais
pas où en trouver et c'est là qu'il me
répond c'est un coup impossible d'être
producteur de spectacles et ne pas
savoir où sévit le brillant et surtout
de ne pas fumer et l'ajustement à table
il avait une jeune fille qui était très
ami avec keith richards des rolling
stones
dia qui est paris on n'a qu'à l'appeler
l'huile il en a sûrement
c'était vrai à temps les cds devrait
donc elle lui a téléphoné et en effet il
est venu avec
[Musique]
de terre
[Applaudissements]
est-ce que première question mais c'est
la plus simple était heureux oui sans
réfléchir deux indices si tous deux
mettent une note aujourd'hui tu dis quoi
cette
amoureuse non ça c'est le drame de ta
vie gold t abx aulas c'est ce qui manque
tu vas les trois points mais pourquoi tu
trouves pas l'amour c'est peut-être lui
qui ne trouve pas mais les hommes que tu
rencontres les rencontres dans quel
contexte loana tu les rencontres soirées
oui parce qu'il ya plein de façons de
rencontrer des gens aujourd'hui et les
applications d es ce que tu as essayé
des choses un peu nouvelle pourrait
séduire l'amour un
autre on fait des rencontres tout le
temps et en fait foi bien sûr mais à
chaque fois tu tombes sur des âmes qui
ne s'intéressaient à moi vraiment je
crois que ça a dû être en 2003 avec noah
ware est sincère et qu'il aimait
vraiment à 20 ans parce que je l'aurais
pas fait si tu étais pas bien mais là
comme tu es très très belle va repasser
ton portrait en 2003 loana 23 ans depuis
cinq ans elle est gogo dancer
avec une certaine image rendront s'axait
je travaille on va donner donc payet
s'est donné des chances très étrange en
fait je train de convertir façon dont
la vocation de loana ce n'était pas de
danser sur des podiums mais ses 17 ans
lorsque sa mère est hospitalisée elle se
retrouve seule pour faire face au
quotidien
on arrive à monte monte monte monte
c'est le sait le paris rio a man 2 il
décroche qu'est-ce qui lé sang de jean
paul gaultier ensuite justement après le
défilé on m'a proposé de faire c'est
cette année
à la halle aux vêtements et puis après
et ben de mauvaises rencontres en sept
rencontres en moins de contre et parce
que voilà parce que tu es fragile des
mauvaises rencontres est choqué c'est à
paris je connais ces personnes aient
fait ça tout seul analyser mon futur
regrette d'avoir fait le loft pas du
tout tu te dis jamais que tu as vu
auraient pu être différentes peut être
non non l'hommage anglade pas d'une
infinie j'en veux à personne n'est
heureux non ma vie elle aurait jamais
été plus belle que si je l'avais pas
fait publier aujourd'hui alors je vis un
peu
en nomade je viens peu cheryl
parce que quand on est ensemble c'est
très bien mais comme on fait les gars là
et bien je suis avec accor
non j'ai pas rivaliser peu partout voilà